cheich or Chong I don't know what that
means
oh do you smoke Weg not as much anymore
oh did you ever smoke while at work not
this work necessarily but I have smoked
at a job before what's your preferred
method of like when you're smoking I
love passing around a joint yeah I love
the social component Puff Pass puff pass
if you found out that an employee was
stoned at work how do you think you'd go
about handling that talking to them I
would ask them if they're okay is
something going on with work that
they're really like stressed about do
you believe in the afterlife I do
because I've recently had a past life
regression can I see your eyes
please so pretty thank you are you high
at work right now I am not okay okay I
believe you okay okay okay okay